non-minimalists
how do you practice self-care without
feeling selfish
ah well here's my pithy answer and maybe
we can we can talk about a little bit
randy my pithy answer is self-care
and selfish reside on opposite sides of
our values
i tend to look at i i look at self
operating
in one's own self-interest which is
self-care
is different from self-ish which is
operating to the detriment of other
people
yeah um how do you differentiate
selfishness from
self-care well to use
the uh brushing your teeth metaphor so
i've never heard um it's where you brush
your teeth
never heard of it okay um interesting
okay
not on my list this explains a lot okay
this uh explains a lot you only do
yeah no like okay brushing your teeth is
something you do every day
and you benefit from it and the people
around you benefit from it
right and so do you feel guilty for
brushing your teeth
do you feel like you're being selfish
like this is really
a new like a great way of approaching
these acts of self-care is it something
that you need to do
to benefit yourself and it benefits
those around you
and you can't fill from an empty cup
right so
um so i say my pithy answer
is self-care is a daily brushing of the
mind
body and soul boom oh my goodness how
dare you come on here and out shout out
bleep that out
make her pit the answer say we could do
a whole podcast about feet
i'll own that i will oh man how about
you ryan
um my pet the answer is to give your
best
to others you must first give your best
to yourself and just to josh's point uh
self-care it only becomes selfish
when it is a detriment to others that's
what you need to look at if you
are doing something for yourself and
it's making someone else
miserable uh then maybe you want to look
at that and be like am i being selfish
right now
but sometimes sometimes here's kind of
the tricky part right sometimes the
self-care that we do it does piss other
people
off and their expectations that they
have they have poor expectations so
we've got to be able to differentiate
when someone has a poor expectation or
if we're the ones that
have a poor expectation so that's again
easier said than done like most of the
stuff we talk about
but uh but the more you practice it the
better you get at it for sure well and
the interesting thing about that too
is sometimes self-care is a really
really hard decision
like the the the more you develop a
relationship with yourself and
i call it your inner wisdom um it
it can sometimes guide you down paths
that are really hard
so it could be you know getting a
divorce
you know moving to a new place that's
that's also self-care
so it we have to be ready to to maybe
make some tough calls sometimes yeah so
yeah i think i think
quite often the expectation thing can be
can be so tricky because
we don't want to let other people down
right
but if i'm letting if i'm if i'm
fulfilling other people's expectations
by letting myself down
that's why i have that that list of my
own sort of self-care these are all
individual acts that's a really good
point
so if you are meeting others people's
expectations but it's letting yourself
down
like that that's a problem right in a
weird way
that is that's an involuted kind of
selfishness when we're
operating only on the behalf of others
dude i was trying to come up with a pity
answer something similar to that because
the the it's selfish to not take care of
yourself in a way i think that's what
you're trying to say yeah yeah
yeah in a weird way it's it's pacifying
others by forsaking the things that are
most important to you
and it's easy to do that because we get
this little dopamine rush when we please
other people and
we all are people pleasers to a certain
extent but i've realized that i mean
you you guys both so for those of you
who don't know randy and
and ryan they're the same person
actually it's the first time i've ever
seen
that i've only seen them in the same in
the same room once right now i'm
actually shocked you're not the same
person
um but they have the same personality
and
um identical personalities and same
sense of humor
and and
and uh what i don't know what's going on
right now we're just connecting
i'm just alone they were doing like the
et finger
no i was double tapping her oh you like
her i got it oh i was softly correct
yourself like pressing my hand
i like that
you